okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about how well from
language applications get to be
standalone on the desktop and we had
talked about previously I think we done
scrambled these options for from script
right - and B do I have a separate
notebook about this someplace you work
directly from the documentation okay did
I edit it you added a tentative - open
option okay so should I go back to that
or what should I do here we can open it
I think we mostly finished with that
area though okay so what was that what
was the thing we were talking about
there so we were considering changing
the UI option - an option that would
open the notebook in general to kind of
separate the execution part from the
opening part so then we would have -
notebook to run or use a notebook and
then - opens actually open the UI yes
okay so - notebook I don't understand
actually why
okay Wolfram script - file we'll run a
file right right so why don't we allow
it to run a notebook as well there could
be slightly separate handling for the
two - thing on how you want them to load
you might want to do different script
things for a file for a notebook you
really just want to kind of launch it as
is with notebook open they end up with
slightly different handling underneath
no no I understand that but but but but
the case look the cases that we're
looking at here are okay so one case is
we have Wolfen script - file
ba ba ba and B and what that should do
is run the inputs in this file
do you agree what does - file do in
terms of yeah okay and return the last
output I think that's right think that's
possible Garrett's deep what's your
concern about it I'm just trying to
think through the process in my head so
I would have to open and check if it's a
notebook and I think that's - I can tell
by the extension yeah you can tell by
the extension 100% of the time okay if
the extension is good enough then that
covers that I think yeah okay runs the
inputs in this file so then the -
notebook case isn't real here correct
great we can kind of merge that with -
file was it in there before weird - and
be in in this version now it's not it's
not documented royde great okay okay so
okay so that's that case so then the
next case is I think Wolfram scrip -
open
and then a notebook
now we can even have multiple notebooks
here presumably
I'm not making sense it could is there
any other arguments we would want i
would conflict with it I'm not sure
about that I'm not sure I I think this
would be okay but but um I'm not sure if
we want to allow multiple ones there
okay the next issue actually just being
brought up on our live stream um how it
well okay they answered the question how
a - code and - function different the
difference between those is - code
explicitly runs and returns the results
of running the code so for example if I
runs - code by one rule from script -
code - plus - I get back for if I say
well from script - function right I'm
gonna do a much more complicated thing
here right and that's primarily useful
for when you're inside a file that's
gonna create something which which takes
arguments on the command line right
great so an interesting issue is the
template file that also might take
arguments on the command line see there
right tree so that's - file ok runs the
inputs okay so now the other case is
well from script so - function is um the
code and then it takes arguments um and
then we've
got well from script how does this work
this is um - template and that's gonna
be a a notebook we got a bunch of
background noise by the way here okay so
so then that's the case of a template
notebook
okay we're basically we're running that
will be the equivalent of document
generate the equivalents have run the
document generator right with those
arguments that make sense yep
okay now this case is just open the
notebook on the screen right and then
that potentially has things like - menu
theme blah blah blah to deal with the
menus right yep okay so now different
for each notebook only on platforms
where there can be different menus for
each notebook no I'm like like many like
there's no menus or menus so some
notebooks may have menus some others on
a Mac my friend there's only one set of
menus I'm looking on a Windows machine I
know I know I know
so I'm saying I'm saying I think what we
should do there is you can set on a per
notebook basis the menus if you really
want to I I let's not get into that
right now let's just have a general menu
theme here okay okay um
what about opening a set of books at
specific locations on the screen you
know like basically like restoring some
sort of yes that's organized workspace
like basically whatever you have on the
screen right now right yeah I understand
so some of the issues here are how to
organize notebooks on the screen okay
we've got several issues that we need to
be looking at here another issue brought
up on the live stream and I was also
going to bring it up is the
initialization cells in the notebook
what do you do in this case do you run
the initialization cells
now I mean that will have I mean I
suspect that we kind of want a thing
that says run in it which is kind of
making it seem less and less likely that
we want to have multiple notebooks here
and that if you want to have multiple
notebooks you want to do it by by using
an actual by by having an actual script
that that has the notebook speed be
started up so to speak okay so the
alternative would just be a you know a
hash-bang wolfram script thing in which
you have actual commands here let's say
things like a notebook open whatever it
is that makes sense because once you're
doing that you can do anything you want
okay this is just the L cheaper way to
do that so if we want to open and
evaluate the entire notebook
what kind of combination of options do
you want for that uh I think that's not
a common case I have to tell you I think
if you want to evaluate non
initialisation Terry why would you want
to do that if you want to do that you
mean like it would flash up for a few
seconds while it's running yeah it just
seems kind of silly I think you should
do that from an actual wolfram script
script okay okay now question on well
that's it
point our livestream weather weather -
file could be omitted as a default if
you say wolfram script and then adjust
it what happens right now if you just
say well from script and then some
random thing helps if it's a file does
that what does that do
that's really weird so if it doesn't
detect an argument
it'll just use the default record and
we'll go into the interactive mode if
the first argument is a notebook or a
file then that actually matches the way
that scripts are passed so it has to
handle that case as a script interpreter
so it's kind of a shortcut that we
haven't documented it that way I'm sorry
what are you talking about what so if
you just do wolfram script and then like
a test w/o us or something like that
it'll open the script and run it well
why did it not do it in this case here
well just give me an hour that's not a
script right it doesn't know it ffff is
where didn't give me an error um it
probably could but it's it's just
ignoring it it's according it is garbage
input okay so if I say well from script
and then I say ffffff wls still ignored
it doesn't exist I think it should give
an error in both of those cases I think
it should give an error I think the
original wolf from toddy X C would had a
few arguments but would start in just
kind of interactive mode if you gave it
you know I don't think we should worry
about that okay um okay yeah Brian I
live stream is pointing out basically we
get ourselves tremendously tangled up if
we have all in one file in this
interactive mode here I don't think we
should um there's a question about a -
template and what that really means and
what about an XML template for example
I think the right thing to do is to look
at the file type here
and to allow any kind of template that
we can support
dot XML dot HTML you know we can support
various kinds of template types dot txt
etc because we have those and those will
that this will use that will use XML
template
and that's an interesting case because
what will this do yeah that will then
return an XM a piece of XML which could
then be ingested or even served back by
a web browser to a web browser that
makes sense so in other words the case
this case welcome script
you
- template bah-bah-bah dot XML or doubt
HTML would basically return an HTML file
after executing the appropriate pieces
inside the HTML template make sense
makes sense to me and it sounds useful
but most of the template functions have
different options
I'm like a insertion function combiner
function things like that you know it if
you want all those things write the code
okay
I think that the defaults are just fine
um
right I mean it's gonna do a template
apply but it's got to know the this
template apply default to the right file
type if you give it a think it's file
templates apply is that right I can put
the ref page on there there's a go to go
to file template apply yeah the first
one that's probably the function we want
to call because you give it a file and
arguments yeah but does it know from the
type of the file doesn't know what's
going on doesn't look like it well it
just splices it in writes like did the
splices in these that the second
argument it doesn't care what it is
just splice this in the stuff the
arguments I know but it needs to know
where to splice it it's got various
splicing things you see what I'm saying
that's not the right thing that's done
with the backticks right there back
techno it's not I know but that's only
for a string if you're using HTML it's a
different way of indicating whether
where the content goes in know what I'm
saying if you've got a notebook it's yet
different again so I'm confused whether
it is on the live stream mentions and I
agree completely that some you know -
template results dot JSON you know -
args blah blah blah would be really
useful I mean you don't even need
necessarily the - args because this in
fact in the template file right that's
the whole point a template file can have
things which just evaluate inside the
template file to get what I'm saying no
thinking I'm thinking sorry just don't
let soar not my
Forte's okay so this is the point this
thing here angle bracket Expo see that's
what's super cool you could have
something there in the JSON file that
has for example angle bracket star you
know now plus you know I know how sunset
open close right and that will then turn
into I don't know what the heck that
we're doing JSON but let's not worry
about that we could do an export string
to JSON or whatever it whatever it needs
to do there and it will just insert that
into the JSON file so you could say you
know time column whatever and it will
just work that's super useful yeah get
it yeah yeah I was confused about the
file template apply it I thought the
file templates by Chuck a file but it
generates a file so that's completely
different fine
okay I see I see right it's it's the
it's the way of doing okay there is no
function it looks like death you know
takes a file and spits out a file right
right so there's so here we have to look
at the type and then decide what type of
template to apply and again if you don't
like those heuristics then use an
explicit hash-bang tell you know how's
bang thing okay so you have given okay
so this - UI is now gone it's been
replaced by - open right great okay and
then
um
okay and run a net is whether to run the
initialization files rather rather to
run the initialization cells um
obviously okay so then I think it will
be super useful to have um
I agree with you that window size is a
useful thing to have
um and I think we should have so like
we'd have - window sighs and then I
think we should have window size full
that just falls as a full screen because
again I think that's gonna be useful
I think window size takes if we have it
as a option already so we should just
support you know third fold how could we
have a windows as an option that is not
fair well from scripts but in the
language oh yeah sure yeah of course we
do but although I think window size is
an option
yeah it has this full notion fine I
don't know whether you can do the two
cases the width and height I I would um
I mean unfortunately we also have to
know where the window is placed on the
screen and that may be I honestly I
think the full screen case is useful the
other case this case I am dubious about
because I think it you know we don't
even know the screen size I mean we can
provide this but I I don't think it's
going to be that useful make sense
okay um okay so the thing I want
talk about is in the hash-bang wall from
scriptcase how do you get all of these
things to happen okay so
script file case script file so that so
what we would have is it would begin
hash-bang wall from script okay and then
among the things you might do you could
say notebook open and then the name of
your notebook ah there's a problem here
wait a minute what if you want to give
oh you know what we've got a case we're
not dealing with him what if the
notebook content is on standard in
so I'm saying great what happens with
the file case wasn't when it's on
standard in do you say well from script
- and then and then it reads from
standard in I believe that works we
should check that okay so well from
script - and then less than stood in and
so what is that going to do then that's
going to be the equivalent of a
hash-bang wolfram script is that right
great
okay so a case that we're not dealing
with that is what if you read a notebook
on I mean maybe that's too exotic you
read a notebook on standard in I'm just
worrying about pipeline type stuff where
you know a notebook comes from somewhere
and then you're trying to process it
somehow alright there's the case where
we'd have to kind of read the first few
lines and have some heuristic to check
if it's a notebook um I don't know about
that well we've got the file format
function which tries to answer that
question right okay let's just look here
for menu themes are supported minimal
notebook manipulate and palette
okay those sound good to me why don't we
have that list here many themed there we
go so that you're saying um
well little weird I mean your dare
screenshots below just gonna see what
they look like would look like okay if I
remember correctly yeah so that's the
normal one the menu theme notebook ass
just with the menus right
minimal is just the same thing but
without two notebooks or that matters on
Windows may not matter as much but wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait this has
all kinds of crud in its menus right I
mean but most of those menus are
irrelevant for most people
well maybe that's the minimum no I don't
know what I meant by minimal I mean hold
on themes and aquila manipulate is just
a much tighter wrapped thing around a
you know control okay but this isn't a
menu theme thing this is a this is a
right right right we which should be
called the theme or something or some
something different there was I think we
covered it last time menu seemed it's
not the right thing but okay there's two
different issues here okay so let's
write down these these these options
okay so election off front end and
notebook settings that affect the appear
right so appearance options basically
okay so what are they so there is let's
just write down all of them okay okay so
one of them is window size okay which
can be width well I think it can be full
it can probably be with the height or wh
it's it's a lot of course right I mean
it's it's whatever options off dollar
for an aunt gives you I mean that that's
everything like that is no I mean what
are you talking about well for for vote
from scripts right there may be a few
like a has no I know I know I know I
know what I'm talking about what we're
gonna provide on the command line here
right well you can provide elsewhere is
a whole different story right okay you
want to point to some sort of yeah it's
a different thing okay so now - theme
okay so this is overall menu appear
overall window overall windows /
notebook appearance okay then I think we
need a thing called - menus and then we
need um a - run in it to run
initialization okay so theme I don't
disagree with what you're proposing here
I don't know what minimal I don't
understand the difference except for
Windows what's the difference - minimal
and non minimal did the menu by okay but
that's only relevant for Windows and
Linux I think as well as Linux so two
out of three okay but that has no menus
at all as what you're telling me
correct well and minerals just like you
know you're good and I think that what
we want to do then is to have that be
one of the options for menus is none
right and don't have that be the the
notebook appearance that's just a menu
option great okay that's a window
element so we can just change that for
each
sorry what what's that mean right
right but I mean so that that means that
the menus in the kit with we're giving
an option for menus and on Mac that will
be the centralized menus on the other
platforms it will be the per per window
menus right so okay I have to look into
getting rid of the menus on Mac it's
possible don't be possible it may just
give an error in that case or something
or it may do something different okay so
um okay so I think that that means none
if possible okay okay so full his
standard menus all standard menus
okay standard menus for all from desktop
okay okay um
okay now we've got other menu
configurations for example um a Wolfson
programming lab oh my gosh okay it has
its own menus right so if you look at
its menus right you see that they are
simpler let's take a screenshot of those
menus okay yeah that's in the menu setup
TR file indeed it is but right there you
need to launch it with a custom user
base directory basically other point
which I don't know how okay the question
of how you pick up the menu set up TR I
don't know okay we talked to John folks
about this they you know I think we
agreed we're not gonna have an arbitrary
menu set up TR we're going to have a
limited set of menu configurations which
are banks switchable between and they're
making sense yeah but it right but it
needs okay it needs to live somewhere in
your you know it's a file I mean it's
reeling from a file so the file has to
be generated and it has to live
somewhere anyway to point to it so I'm
just saying good exactly all of that
right yes all of those things need to
happen
okay back to this so now
this is the wulfing desktop ones whoops
oh my gosh
did I get a pasting bug again oh my gosh
that was I did a screen capture and
didn't paste properly and it's beeping
again um that is the bug that is that
crazy bug do you know what I'm talking
about
aa node not sure - well this is a bug
that I've reported for like a year so
there's an intermittent bug for the
finnex pasting of images is a zoom
related orestes no it has nothing to do
a zoom and if I make a new window here
it'll paste just fine if I go back to my
original window it'll paste just fine
now okay and previously beeped saying
the key combination didn't do anything
which is kind of stupid okay in any case
all right so you see there are different
menus in these two cases right so did we
did we have a list of potential menu
themes from before no just just just one
think I took the current list is from
the urgent list okay but you you got you
confused that if I might say so because
you turned those into complete themes
right which they were not okay okay so
that's just it's just not not correct so
yeah this isn't right um so here I would
they have to write down what's in each
of those um each of those many cases um
so I think let's write them down okay so
the first case is full I would say for
wool from desktop Oh actually actually
um we've got another case here the first
case we have is inherited which is um
you know whatever your which is the
default am I making sense which is
whatever your desktop Wolfram language
application is default is to go what I'm
saying is that the same as automatic
better to be automatic here
or inherited I don't know what which one
is better okay so that's that's me that
gets it from that okay so none is no
visible menus I don't think that's
possible on Mac well you can give a menu
set up that TR that's almost empty you
probably still have to Apple menu until
the Wolfram desktop
thing because don't you yeah okay
but the rests is probably like no
visible menus except Apple plus brother
app name yeah whatever your products
whatever product you're wolfram script
is pointed to right exactly
okay so full well from desktop menus I
would say is that case right yeah I'm ER
or Mathematica or whatever well it's the
same though the same aren't they
[Music]
we might should we see if we can get Lou
here he would know yeah I think yeah
okay let me try to get him okay
meanwhile Andre knows a lot about these
customizations of you know product
customization with menus but alex is
cutting away um and yeah Andre will be
useful as well uh okay Brian our live
stream is asking for a window position
option um oh you had one up there but he
wanted to have a comma in there not sure
why but he wanted to no I did not have a
window position I had a window size but
not a window position oh okay yeah the
problem with window position we don't
have a window position option in the
front end um we have a window margins
option all right
and I don't know what window position is
supposed to mean that is is it you know
what's the coordinate system I think
it's like wherever your Apple menu is
that's that's zero zero okay well if we
do that we probably should have a window
position option in the front end as well
I don't disagree that this is useful but
the problem is you have to think about
what it does you know what if your
window is what if your screen is small
blood bla bla bla bla yeah okay
so again we're gonna we're going to come
back in a second to the menus but the
other case that I want to understand is
Luis here okay can we get everything we
need just okay well alright
what what is command line deploy and
what is the relevance of this to any of
this stuff so command line deploy
basically takes some contents and
creates the appropriate you know wls
file that you can run so can be you know
can be notebook and then you know it'll
open that notebook it can be a cell can
be a manipulates I mean you know it
refers of what we're doing here it's
basically the Wolfram language you know
wrapper around something that creates a
Wolfram language scripts no it's not
it's the inverse of what we're doing
here so what this is gonna do is come
online deploy an image of cat you know
yeah so in other words when you go to
that file if you look inside it'll say
hash-bang Wolfram script and if you run
that file it will take picture of a cat
it will show the cat yeah I mean cats
are kind of like you know parenthetical
here I mean actually I know there's no
actual cat
no no there's great it would just
basically used it you know the Wolfram
desktop as an image viewer so just you
know open a notebook that's tightly
wrapped around the image of a cat
like that that's what I imagine it would
do right okay so let's take the example
here so this is really pretty cool I
mean this is then taking examples of
manipulate then that is going to
basically do all the plumbing to give
you a file which when you run it on the
desktop will just bring up that
manipulate yeah pretty much right with
you know with the right menu like a
minimal menu probably and you know just
something that kind of you know looks
almost like an application the way you
just you know all year exactly yeah your
interface is just you know the sliders
and things like that then well exactly
yeah right exactly so what it's gonna do
is it's gonna come up with it's going to
be the analog of no attractions or
fourth menus no no no no I understand
but it's the analog here of menus - none
um okay uh okay Brian on our live stream
is asking will the generator wls file
contain a standard mime file type like
the dot NB file
well that's more done with the operating
system as far as I know I'm not sure how
you put mine well no the issue the issue
that they're pointing out which is an
important issue is if what you deploy
there is a notebook right
what does the actual oil is like what
does this actually look like right so in
other words let's say okay so we've got
command line deploy can I say one thing
with regard to okay the wls file we when
you run the Installer whether it's a
Wolfram desktop installer or a
mathematic installed already Wolfram
script installer it sets the you know
the type of the file in the operating
system so it you know it makes it an
executable thing you know beyond that
you know mime types are not typically
stored inside the file yeah yeah yeah I
understand I understand but but so let's
look at this case okay let's look at the
case where I'm making this notebook okay
where I'm making a complete notebook
into the script right so okay what does
the script look like in that case the
script is going to say actually this
grits just fine the script is just gonna
basically say this discreetly open it up
okay it will be a tiny little script
that basically opens you know no no but
the notebook is inside the script
there's no secondary they sure yeah it's
notebook open off that thing no no put
or notebook put or well yeah whatever
yeah that's the point that's the point
of making this is a one file you know
one stop I spend all from scripts next
time is notebook boot of that notebook
expression of the notebook expression
yeah and then it just opens to know um
maybe with like minimal theming if if I
mean we can discuss that but this is
super useful stuff in my view um
okay so then that turns into you're
saying hash-bang welcome sure that you
line up we put off notebook off xxxxxx
and that can be you know five gigabytes
long as far as we're concerned doesn't
matter
there's welcome script automatically do
things like using front end well it
should if it doesn't then you know we'll
put whatever but this in fact this
hash-bang line can have options on it it
wants to my question was more does the
using print end have to be part of the
the script file it could be necessary
but if it's necessary no we just add it
right great
it'll just it'll have to be the
expression whatever is necessary to get
it you know to start up it's it's all
about just making you know have a
command lines good cuz the wls is just
you know that's an executable thing now
so that's really useful so that when you
type that you know it can do all sorts
of useful thing you know such as you
know putting up an image or putting up a
notebook or you know evaluating 1+1 or
you know running so API function I mean
you know that's the idea that's
wonderful right this is super useful I
mean this is this people have been
asking for this for like years decades
right um okay let's see what about
deploying it as an app for distribution
okay so that is a different issue so the
issue is that then you have to put the
wool from engine inside it and that is
the final thing that's the final icing
on the cake right is um
final icing is deploy awls file then
bundled with an installable wolfram
engine right great
so originally you suggested like an
include engine type of option
what if edited different name than that
but the idea was for it to kind of copy
over the engine into the layout the
tricky part is how do you secure that so
that the licensing is reasonable and how
do you make it so someone can't just
switch whatever script out they want
into it
sure well I mean that that's okay so
look the yes Ethan on our live stream
says packaging wolfram engine into an
Xcode project may involve complicated
licensing questions indeed it does for
everybody Xcode and us and everybody
it's a big mess um
you
yeah so right I mean that's the point is
what we want is a is a wolfram engine
that is sufficiently tightly wrapped
with this with a digital signature which
by the way is and that's not very hard
to put in right you have a digital
signature that says this engine can only
run
I feel like the free Wolfer mention that
we're working on I mean that would be
good for that yes right can only run
with this file right so I looked at
doing it with Wolfram engine itself and
the problem is if you you know
distribute this out or make you know
several different applications then
someone will have to activate each of
those engines that doesn't fit very well
with their current licensing so having
some kind of signature I think would
work better but we'd have to yeah right
but that's I think that's something for
the crypto folk why don't you ask I mean
that's a good Roman and Daria and those
guys who are working on crypto stuff
because I think that's an application of
their that should be an application of
vegetal signature stuff
um so Brian our live stream is hopefully
saying sign the script and put the
signature at the end and have the engine
validate script before running it yes
yes I agree but that we now have the
very beautiful capability that has it's
all nicely packaged which says generate
hopefully generate digital signature of
hello what does it asking me for it so
it's asking me for my public key
right asymmetric keeper and now it's
asking me for that
I was actually asking me for that
private key I think I'm not mistaken
oh for goodness sake it's got to be a
freaking elliptic curve key yes hum
there we go
now it is um yes and brian on our
livestream is saying create a portal
where app developers can submit their
app for signing yup exactly so right
thumb there's one more trick with that
so without actually installing the
engine if you just have it bundled in
the app then the WS file won't know
where the engine is or where wolfram
script is so unless there's like an
execute we launch it from an executable
or something like that it's hard to set
everything up all right this is we have
to cross this bridge later let's get
everything else working and let's get
unless this is going to affect the way
the command line deploy function works
which you don't think it is
hey I mean come online deploy is the
direct analog and we designed this a
couple of years ago is the direct analog
of cloud deploy basically it can take
all kinds of random junk and basically
turn it into a standalone script right
and that script will be referring to the
default wolfram script correct
so in fact command line deploy needs an
option now that I think about it which
is wolfram script location or something
or from script path something like that
that doesn't that's your typing on the
command on the command line you type you
know script up wls so you know that's
gonna launch whatever wolfram script is
you know being used for that no no I
understand that but script o wls will
contain hash-bang will from script it
doesn't know to say hash-bang slash user
slash local slash war from script not
sure how that works on windows tail
because i think on the windows there's
one wolfram script that's registered ok
fine but on on any Linux on any UNIX
based system you can say
something like in that you could say
there you know yeah okay now I don't
know whether I don't know how that's
gonna work in terms of distributing the
thing okay this is a complicated thing
but we have to think about um you know
there's a simpler sub project which is
just you know the command line deploy
without all the yes and that's a very
important project yeah okay I mean some
of that is some of this is very
straightforward I think because this is
essentially the way this should work is
its synthesizing a Wolfram script
command line if I'm not mistaken right
great there's some tricky parts like
what do you do for a form function do
you generate the form and keep the copy
over the graphics or do you generate the
graph of us you don't worry about that
case at the beginning okay cuz I don't
even know what the form should be I mean
what should the form be you could have
you know it could be a form in I have no
idea I mean it could be running in no
js' it could be running in in a notebook
it could be running another thing we
should just set up a new packet Gerrits
okay that that's just called command
line deploy or whatever okay and we
start with the 1+1 case okay and then
we'll just have cases as we go along
right
I think the form function case is quite
complicated yeah there's a lot of simple
cases in here as well there are there's
a lot of cases that are very interesting
like the API function case is very
interesting that that case will be very
very nice
um and I assume we also want
command-line deploy of delayed that's
also a useful case right yeah well
there's a one comes 1k so I would hope
that that was already delayed in this
way by default it should you should have
to put in delay this should be just like
cloud deploy okay so in other words if
you say 1+1 it's gonna kind of deploy -
it's nicely ok and in this case it will
deploy 1+1 but
strip off the delayed exactly but if you
say right if you say here deploy now
that will be more interesting yeah file
will then contain now that's correct
that one will be a Wolfram script file
that contains now that runs now um
what's that runs now now so to speak and
returns you know returns the results of
now yeah at that time okay um okay
so let's go back here to the menu
configurations okay so the thing we
wanted Lou here for was was in this
thing we are planning to have particular
configurations of menu setup TR for
different kinds of deployment right okay
is this making sense to you so far I
mean this is this is what you'll do is
you'll be able to say well from script -
open and then a notebook but you'll also
be able to give their - menus um and
that will tell you what menus to bring
up when you open that notebook because
there's gonna be this is gonna be
opening there's gonna be opening the
whole you know a whole front end and
this is telling it what notebooks to
open when it opens okay actually there's
another thing that we could provide here
which is um is there a splash screen
does that a meaningful thing - what is
it called launch screen or something -
uh what would you call that thing is it
called a splash screen it's not splash
screen is from very you know from 1970s
style 1980s style computing I know we do
have such a screen on our UNIX and
Windows products but not on Mac I don't
know if we have that support on Mac
anymore okay question mark question mark
so that if if we had that then it would
be provided essentially as a bitmap
presumably
but true
anybody knows loot as a PNG or somesuch
yes yeah okay okay so next um okay then
let's go back here Oh where were we okay
let's talk about menus alright so um
ah okay wait a minute
um
[Music]
okay Brian says windows will use dot wls
to decide to run the engine um
brian says on windows you could create a
console window that is running the
script command processor that reads the
input from the command line like
Microsoft does with the PowerShell
window this is what I get for the fact
that my Windows machine has been dead
for waiting for its upgrade to version 2
Windows 10 to actually have everything
be deployed correctly and I have not
been using Windows for a while as a
result of that um but oh no do you
understand what what what's being talked
about there yeah it I think he's talking
about just prompting so you know if you
don't give the appropriate arguments and
it says it's expecting certain arguments
he'll just boot prompt up sir oh I see I
see I see that's useful yeah that's a
good idea
that's a good idea that it can give ya
right that's the case for up up in
wolfram script here that's the case
where you've given - where the function
here expects ogz but you didn't give the
augs yeah I can just figure Arkin
sensory screenshot right right right
that's a junior vote that's a really
good case that's a really really good
case um it's if if args aren't given
you'll go ahead on the command line it's
a really useful case but it's also a
little bit difficult because the place
where the functions processed is in the
kernel but the place where the arguments
are right in will be in the C side of
Wolfram script but Garrett it already
knows what arguments it's expecting
right very if it doesn't have the
arguments it needs then what you need to
do is simply run in put in in Wolfram
language input you simply go through and
you you you simply look at the arguments
that have been provided you look at the
arguments that's looking for you say oh
there are some missing okay just execute
input of blah blah blah to get those
arguments okay yes
with function will you always know which
arguments it's expecting I know you will
can yes okay yes because because what it
does here don't you have to give this
signature or something or you don't have
to give the signatures yes yes signature
well the signature so they say signature
if you give the signature but not the
arguments right that's thing you know
what to do
it's a dead giveaway okay I'll send you
screenshots what it looks like right let
me also point out another thing which is
um just an implementation detail those
things what you want to do is is hijack
the interpreter message stuff to get the
right thing to happen let me show you
did you understand what I'm saying what
about I mean by that so what I mean by
that is something like this if you if if
if the signature said it was supposed to
be an integer right and you say this
right it'll say that right if you can
pick that up then you can have a nice
command-line interaction let me see
yeah that will be tricky because that's
another case where I would have to go
back from Wolfram language to see to
reap romped why why why it's just all
open language prompts okay so the
Wolfram language would issue I'm just a
message yeah what do you what you do is
you do look at it but here's what you do
use input okay that brings up this okay
and you put in something there and you'd
say okay okay so now what does that do
on a command line answer here if I say
input here and I say prompt for example
right and that's what it does okay great
it's real simple
um yeah it'll just work and further
cloud we won't be able to do that
thank you for your modernity uh node now
how do I copy this thing out probably
zoom in a little bit but can't resize it
it's a really small right now you cannot
click on it and copy it
um it's not important I just want to
show you that the PowerShell thing I
think I can copy this all right this is
like a little click on the image I did
click on the image I did I can copy the
image to UM Macon's resize okay I think
that's what the yeah yeah exactly
yes exactly so Brian right yes yes yes
um okay
so this will be really nice that's a
really good mechanism thank you for that
suggestion ah okay okay
ah let's see where were we um
we were going back to talking about the
menus right so the thing comes up and
there are these different themes Lou um
a notebook theme
a
let's see do we have a list of themes
here we didn't have the list of themes
we need um themes here so the themes are
I would say notebook which is just a
standard notebook um we had manipulate
which is just a single manipulate I
would argue that we should have a theme
that a cell
it's a single cell
maybe
suggested a palette theme okay which is
floating presumably so these are all
things where you could take a notebook
that you are opening on the screen and
decide how much what what does it mean
when you say manipulate is that a shrink
wrapped around a manipulator what yeah
and the other notebook scroll up just a
little bit they're not very well defined
yet but it's basically like yeah you
have a control typically manipulates and
you just built a notebook with no menus
around it as as small as you can but
remember you're thinking about my okay I
also dialog listed is an alias for it so
its uses a lot of the dialogue style
definitions and things like that
Lulla you with us can you comment on any
of this well yeah I mean there's lots to
comment on one is that manipulates
change sizes so locking down a window
size to be tight around a manipulate is
sillies in battle right okay and
manipulate is a cell I'm not sure how
manipulate and cell themes are going to
be different may be manipulated is going
to be seemed in such a way that makes it
more interactive II interactive looking
somehow it rings that dinner bell yeah
okay so your your claim is if I have a
notebook okay so look let me paint two
cases okay
well what happens if I have a manipulate
um and I say something like graphics of
disk and then I say um
uh image size arrow W and then I say W
goes from a hundred to eight hundred for
example okay fine so now I go OOP okay
fine
so now I would say one case is the
notebook case it would look like this it
would have all kinds empty space down at
the bottom
well can the window size automatically
updates to fit right around the
manipulates manipulates size we can try
I'm not sure that that's bug free but
we've been we've been doing that for
instance for palettes for some time and
was it like 80 percent working I think
it might be better than that but I don't
think it's bug free nothing ever is 90
percent if you're gonna put me down yeah
I mean you can get the box Isis
basically like the you can look at the
cell and then look at the first box
that's inside it and get the size of
that box or something is that how you
would do it no there's a window size
setting fit or fit all okay that does
that automatically okay so you can just
use that and then you know so if I set
the window size here so if I say set
options Oh notebook notice you have two
cells here and they have they have cell
margins no so what happens if I say
window size are a fit or something here
try list fit comma fit with just the
word fit like that symbol oh very
exciting oh my gosh moving out from
under your mouth yeah I tore a
horrifying yeah I mean then many aspects
of this that are horrified that it works
yeah but it does work my gosh that's
really in in the world of UX you know
insanities that's pretty high up there
so we did develop a manipulate option
for demonstrations that will lock down
the size of the manipulate in a couple
of different ways one is we allow users
to specify a content size literally for
a manipulate yes and another was a way
to have the dynamic grow but never
shrink
by setting I think it's shrinking delay
to infinity you don't use that for
manipulate we use it for animate but it
could be used here okay but how common
is that that manipulates grow in size I
mean I would never
Oh super common but it's not unheard of
right manipulates that that just change
in size I mean it's I always make an
effort that they don't change your size
because it kind of bothers me so well if
you're doing math for instance you don't
know what the answer is going to be for
different values in the parameter space
you know expand X plus y to the end yeah
I mean look but there are some
manipulates that change size and there
are many that don't that's the basic
bottom line um okay on the left is more
typical I think right
which doesn't transpose so so fine so
okay look it seems to me that Lou and
you guys need to work together to come
up with I mean so with respect to the
menus let me just say what I think we
want roughly I think we want the full
menus I think we want something that's
more like programming lab menus and I
think we want something that's minimal
so I think we should say full I think we
want simplified and I think we want
minimal um and I would assume minimal I
mean Lou you can and now okay next
question for users to set this up
themselves is it plausible or is it way
too complicated to set up the menus
themselves it's fairly complicated
can I read in a menu set up to your file
and see what it looks like
where is my menu set up to our file it's
in a platform specific sub sub sub
directory of who the find file may be
fine film I can find it no fine fine I
won't find it oh do text search that's
not gonna work is it yeah well I mean I
can okay look I can I can find it with
my big elephant thing here often this
the elephant is not it's just no the
elephant was lost um I could probably
find it with the Mac finder top-tier
that what I want menu setup TR I think
so yeah there's one yeah yeah that's
okay that's not bad horrifying excuse me
that's not that horrifying I mean
actually it's quite less looking it's
readable yeah I mean this is not this is
not absolutely insane for using we have
we have never suggested that users
modify this or any other text resource
file themselves do I understand that I'm
just kind of but but in principle we
could at least have a simplified version
we could prepackaged several choices
sure yeah like a stylesheet too you know
exactly that's what I'm suggesting and
I'm suggesting that we pick ones that
are suitable for look but basically
there's the full case there's the
simplified case which is eg you know
education related files save in a file
you know copy-paste maybe those are
things yeah yeah exactly basically not
not a lot of well and and but if you
look at the one for programming lab it's
got some stuff in it like under advanced
and this apply not the right place for
it there's this you know some of these
things this type of stuff okay Steven
can I point out something the menu bar
is only one place where menus are
available few options you are right like
there to right-click menu there's
context menus all over the place when
you might not think about is there's a
context menu on the dock icon and even
thought of
right okay okay so look the basic point
is we all have these other things and
unfortunately I have to go so we have to
wrap right now to be continued if you
guys can meet separately and talk a bit
about these menus that will be really
helpful
yep okay that's scary okay and you have
access to this SW notes file you have
that you like show where it is I have
access to it okay there it is okay
could you give me a copy of it yes oh
that's okay I have to run I'm sorry guys
um and thank you very much to folks on
the livestream a lot of very useful
comments for us today
Thanks okay see y'all soon bye thank you